dizem por aí que o marinheiro quando não
está no mar está no bar e foi assim que
a minha vida começou no ritz em 1982
para barman do ritz é e comecei a
competir quando comprei meu primeiro
catamarã hobie cat 16 e durante dez anos
seguidos eu competir mas a minha noiva a
minha vida na noite continuou 85 com
dois amigos em abril cingapura desligue
87 aeroanta e 89 o livro de alguns
clientes aqui que eu já vi
é minha vida como competidor foi muito
bem e depois de dez anos não sabia muito
bem pra que lado eu ia uma conversa
despretensiosa com o marcos baquero um
amigo meu
nós decidimos fazer uma viagem de manhã
para ele a bela ea iniciou uma série de
viagens que resultaram em mais de 60 mil
quilômetros em barcos em cabine
a primeira viagem foi entre trópicos
justamente por ser a primeira a gente
não tem muita experiência foi escolhido
um trajeto um pouco mais seguro pelo
fato de a gente viajar por águas quentes
não saímos de miami
vejamos do caribe pra em praia
atravessamos toda amazônia pela
venezuela está chegando em belém e
descemos à costa brasileira e por causa
do barulho ser tão pequenininho tão
desprovido de de conforto a gente
apelidou a os barcos de jangadas high
tech mix é não tinha muito lugar para
levar nosso equipamento a carga
normalmente quem viaja num barco
cabinado pelo mundo tem todos os
recursos nossos barcos são muito
pequenininho sentam todos os dias a
gente tem que parar em alguma praia uma
ilha para dormir
essa viagem dura 289 dias
quando eu cheguei ele a bela foi um
choque em pensar que eu passei dez meses
em cima um barco tão simples ensino ano
tão feliz e os meus a minha mala pessoal
tinham três bermudas três camisetas e
uma sandália havaiana foi um ano com tão
pouca coisa que eu vivi também a segunda
viagem alguns anos depois
bem oposta a primeira uma viagem fria
mais desafiadora pelo fato da gente
dobrar o cabo horn um barco sem cabine
havia feito uma viagem então é radical
o sul da américa do sul um lugar onde
tem muito vento muita tempestade
aqui as dormidas acampamentos serão mais
difícil explicar as praias ano de pedras
e nem sempre a gente encontrava pra essa
viagem durou 170 dias e quando nós
chegamos no rio de janeiro depois de
terminada a viagem e pensei eu pensei
bom hoje mas nós somos capazes de e veio
a idéia de atravessar o trecho
por que um amigo havia brincado com
música havia dito que nós já vimos subir
o everest e sandália havaiana ea
travessia do drake era um salto muito
grande em logística e segurança pelo
fato da gente atravessar o pior do mundo
com esse barco nessa viagem nós não
tínhamos dois barcos se um barco de
apoio foram dois meses
a logística foi uma logística muito
sofisticada e eu considero das sete
viagens a viagem mais perfeita em termos
de logística é no ano seguinte nós
fizemos miami nova iorque numa
competição e 2005 ver rota boreal uma
viagem igualmente fria também num barco
de 20 pés aberto durante 90 e 90 dias
nós exploramos a costa do canadá até
groelândia passado essas cinco viagens
né de norte a sua agente conector
antártica e groenlândia é veio a idéia
de fazer uma viagem oceânica
verdadeiramente atravessar o maior
oceano do planeta o pacífico
só que nesse momento a viagem mudou
completamente porque nós vamos passar
semanas em cima do nosso catamarã é sem
ter onde parar na primeira escala foi de
páscoa que foram 18 dias depois era um
aprendizado novo vinha o questionamento
como que nós vamos dormir como a gente
ia se alimentar e foi um aprendizado
essa viagem foi a mais longa de todas em
termos de distância não dê tempo foi a
viagem que mais quebras o
o fato até do barco não sei exatamente o
barco mais apropriado para isso
em 2013 a mais recente das viagens junto
com igor meu companheiro francês nós
saímos de capital e atravessamos o
atlântico
a diferença dessa viagem em relação a
todas as outras é que essa viagem nós
não tínhamos escalas no dia que a gente
saiu de capital
a gente sabia que a gente ia ter que
pisar o pé numa praia do brasil esperava
que fosse a bela e assim foi
essa é uma foto que mostra bastante o
que é a realidade de uma vida da vida de
um velejador a mar aberto foi uma
tempestade que a gente pegou na costa
dos esqueletos na áfrica e deteve dias
monótonos tivemos dias de calmaria e o
assunto no barco muitas vezes termina ea
gente não tem muito que falar teve um
desequilíbrio falou pra mim assim puxa
betão está frio sim eu falei tá mesmo
assunto tarde daquele dia foi isso e
depois de 37 dias nós chegamos em
ilhabela e tanto a viagem do pacífico
como a travessia do atlântico o que
ficou marcado por orgulho pra mim não
foi propriamente só o feito náutico mas
foi chegar mais amigo do que nós saímos
e isso é uma conquista muito grande
porque a gente sabe que nas relações
humanas são o maior desafio é de todas
as viagens que eu fiz é eu separei uma
história pra contar para vocês hoje aqui
que tem a ver com conexões é que
aconteceu na primeira viagem quando nós
saímos pela floresta amazônica vocês vão
ver no mapa que a gente entra pelo rio
orinoco nós nessa viagem transformamos
os barcos para entrarmos numa foi uma
expedição na floresta um barco continuou
com o mesmo formato mas com motor de
popa porque não tem como ver já dentro
do rio e outro barco a gente transformou
num barco casa como se fosse uma gaiola
contra os insetos estão todos os dias a
gente parar em alguma margem de dormir a
essa viagem foi inspirada no alecsandro
11 que 1.800 descobriu que existe uma
conexão entre a bacia do orinoco com a
bacia amazônica brasileira e nós
sabíamos que nós temos
o contrário e nomes bastante primitivos
quando nós chegamos na tribo esse barco
encostou facilmente o meu que tinha um
astro ficou enroscado nas árvores
rapidamente um dos vídeos subiram subir
subir na árvore e cortou os galhos
eu pensei bom é um sinal de boas-vindas
hoje estão com fome né
bom é nós ficamos conversando assim
conversando distribuímos camiseta damos
comida desidratada pra eles castanhas e
eles rapidamente se recolheram porque já
era fim de tarde eles viviam numa oca
única e nós ficamos sem saber o que
fazer porque eles nos convidaram para
entrar e eu falei pro roberto lista do
dunga meus companheiros a gente podia
fazer a técnica do cachorro sentado à
porta e vai entrando devagarzinho se
eles não falarem nada a gente entra na
oca e entramos na oca e eu fiquei
chocado porque era uma oca única 17
famílias todas em volta do seu fogo com
redes estaqueados cozinhando uma um tipo
de uma raiz e roberto lista vida pra mim
falar assim button o que nós estamos
vendo aqui é a mesma imagem de 3 mil
anos atrás eu falei pra ele então se a
gente entrasse numa máquina do tempo e
viajar três mil anos a gente veria isso
ele falou exatamente eu me dei conta que
eu estava há três mil anos para trás e
eu fiquei imaginando o que eles pensavam
da gente
os barcos estranho né e eu me dei conta
que eles não sabiam absolutamente nada
até cinco anos atrás nunca havia visto
um homem branco e eles sabiam o limite
da floresta
então eu tive a idéia de até o barco
pegar um outro homem e peguei um ótimo
separei uma fitinha do milton nascimento
que eu tinha na época 94 eu separei
sentinela de milton e voltei correndo
para trigo e coloquei o fone de ouvido
um no ouvido do chefe do play a cara que
o índio fez foi
eu e ele ficou olhando aquilo entrar vou
procurar aquela caixinha e aquele senso
de coletividade dos vídeos ele tirou o
fone de o pajé o país já deu pra mulher
do pai do índio e deu para as crianças a
elas levaram o outro núcleo de família e
foi assim com landu de de núcleo núcleo
achei que nunca mais vou me levantar e
mais duas crianças voltaram nós
estávamos sentados no chão e nos
devolveram óculos e cantar um pequeno
cântico e uma música bem curtinha
espontaneamente nós emocionados
aplaudimos as duas crianças
roberto já falou pra mim cantar então eu
fui não sou muito desafinado canta você
e aí é roberto foi lá no meio cantou a
música em espanhol e para nossa surpresa
os índios aplaudiram
então acho que nós ensinamos pelo menos
aquela tribo aplaudido e aí eu tomei
coragem não desculpa aí vieram outras
duas crianças cantaram outro cântico aí
eu tomei coragem e fui cantar eu sabia
que aquele seria o único lugar do mundo
que eu seria aplaudido cantando toninho
horta beijo partido uma música difícil e
é novamente vieram duas crianças
cantaram outro cântico e no final da
canção africano que é meu companheiro
também de muitas viagens
levantou-se no meio ensinou pra gente um
backing vocal em áfrica' e nós cantamos
uma música tribal e essa foi a mais
aplaudida de todas
naquela noite a gente conectada à áfrica
com a floresta amazônica
roberto estica-se voltou pra mim falou
então vamos pra barraca porque o barco
porque índio dorme cedo e nós nos
recolhemos não tentei meu saco de dormir
fiquei pensando sobre o que havia
acontecido
eu não conseguia nem tão emocionado que
eu tava mas essa história ficou gravada
por muitos anos na minha cabeça sempre
voltava essa imagem dessa noite e eu
mesmo sem saber falar e não mama e ele
sem o português ou espanhol para que seu
nome estava na venezuela
é me dei conta que nós comunicamos pela
música a música é um é uma linguagem
universal e muitas vezes a gente fala o
mesmo idioma mas não fala a mesma
linguagem a gente consegue se comunicar
e naquele dia eu me dei conta que a
comunicação quando desprovida de amor é
a morosidade é como uma viagem que
começa e não termina nunca
e eu parti muitas vezes
amo partir porque eu amo chegar muito
obrigado